Call of Duty fans were pleasantly
surprised yesterday when Infinity Ward
live streamed in invite-only Warzone 2.0
event Call of Duty creators like courage
Modern War Zone noisy Butters and more
played the game for their audiences and
showed off a lot of what was detailed in
the most recent Call of Duty blog post
this includes loadouts of various points
of interest and third person mode there
was also of course a lot of looting and
inventory management shown off content
creator repulse took to Twitter to
clarify some confusion about the new
system and said quote they didn't take
anything away they technically just
added you have an on-person inventory
that's your standard war zone 1 system
and then you have your backpack that
adds slots everything in your on-person
inventory Auto picks up seems simple
enough but once fans saw it it happened
to draw a lot of criticism and so did
the DMZ mode as a whole DMZ is an open
world narrative focused extraction mode
where players fight alone or together
with the aim of getting to the child
Chopper to escape on their way players
will take part in faction-based missions
and side objectives as they fight
against other human players or AI
players before x-fill at the end of the
round Iceman Isaac reacted to the mode
and said quote I think DMZ should be
delayed let Warzone 2.0 go crazy on
November 16th and keep working on DMZ
until it's ready Tim the tatman had a
similar reaction and said quote DMZ
looked kind of mad Warzone 2 looks solid
and I'm excited for next week third
person war zone 2 looked lit and even
though Warzone 2.0 is a free to play
game you might want to Fork over some
cash if you're into progressing faster
in a blog post Activision announced that
all Modern Warfare 2 owners will get
premium XP in Warzone 2.0 at the end of
each match anyone who owns MW2 will get
additional XP beyond the normal per
match XP the company didn't specify the
exact multiplier that will be in place
only that it will be greater than
standard XP progression however the this
perk won't last forever a level up
trailer hyping this promotion includes
disclaimer text that specifies this
increased XP payout is only good through
October 2023 but saying goodbye to that
premium XP is so far away what's closer
is saying goodbye to the original war
zone Warzone 1 is being taken offline
for 12 days losing a lot of content and
dropping other features with the launch
of Warzone 2.0 presumably in a bid to
encourage people to play the new game on
November 16th the day that Warzone 2.0
launches the original war zone will be
taken offline starting at 8 A.M Pacific
Time 11 A.M Eastern war zone 2.0 will
launch that day at 10 A.M Pacific 1 pm
Eastern and during this time the
developers will focus on getting the new
game up and running in a blog post
Activision confirmed that the game will
be rebranded Call of Duty Warzone
Caldera and the game is losing a number
of features and functionality Activision
also confirmed that any cosmetic items
you may have purchased from the original
war zone will not carry forward to the
new title hit the comment section let me
know what rank you are in Modern Warfare
2 multiplayer and on a scale of 1 to 10
how excited you are for season one to
start next week I'm in about a nine so
can you beat that